I know that in the in the last few weeks
we've been covering a lot of depressing
stories but I'm afraid I have one more
terrible tale to tell you
Russia has lost contact with a satellite
full of possibly mating geckos Russia
launched the geckos a the space about a
week ago they were trying to observe
their mating activities in zero-gravity
but after just a few orbits their pods
stopped responding to Mission Control
don't you dare offer that don't you dare
laugh at the fact that Russia has lost a
satellite full of sexually active space
geckos there is nothing funny about that
this is like Apollo 13 all over again
only in Cyrillic and with a quintet of
Russian folk lizards instead of Tom
Hanks and frankly Russia has not been
treating this story with the urgency it
deserves
Russia's hoping to restore
communications before the geckos run out
of food hoping that is not good enough
Russia you can't just watch videos of
them and then toss them aside they're
not Kardashians and look you might be
saying Jon why are you making such a big
deal out of this aren't there more
important things going on in the world
well yes obviously almost everything is
more important than this Ukraine is
sliding into anarchy the Gaza ceasefire
in tenuous and we're mostly powerless to
do anything about any of them but maybe
just maybe if we could come together and
accomplish one thing as a civilization
we could then build on that progress and
I think rescuing these space sex geckos
might just be that thing and that is why
I'm issuing a challenge to humanity go
get those geckos now I know what you're
thinking I know what you're thinking
John how is a hashtag going to rescue
those geckos the hashtag is to raise
awareness you idiots
we positive and you can and should do
more you could go on to the Kremlin's
contact page which inexplicably has a
form allowing you to actually write
vladimir putin a letter which you can do
at this address
look take take this seriously don't be
idiots about this the kremlin insists
this is true that your suggestions be
and I quote specific and I do not know
of a more specific suggestion then go
get those geckos I don't know I don't
know I'm not a space pornographer mate
maybe a net of some sort or a magnet I
don't know make maybe you've got some
better ideas and if you do don't tell me
tell vladimir putin at this address we
can do this people and sure Russia's
going to push back like they did
yesterday saying they've reestablished
contact with the satellite but they're
clearly lying they're just buying Putin
enough time to run to a pet store get
five geckos and parade them in front of
us well we don't want those geckos we
want the space geckos
come on humanity let us stand together
as one and let us after
mr. Putin don't tip comes geckos go get
those geckos go get those geckos